you know I was I was thinking that like
first I was like you know you guys must
be so relieved one of the great things
about doing this podcast is you can
actually just talk about like yourselves
and what's going on in your lives and
people aren't bringing up a TV show from
you know decades ago and everything and
then I was like watching the Clips and
it was like yeah but then you got to
talk about your diarrhea and
like which is so much better than
talking about Sopranos
how did you start the podcast did you
like why don't you go like hey let's
just do this or do you just got sick and
you know I want to do something so I uh
I reached out to Jamie and I was like
I'm I was in LA I mean I was in Vegas uh
playing poker and I was sober so I was
just sick of [__] Vegas I was like I
can't be here anymore and I was like if
I moved to LA would you start a podcast
with me and I had the idea to do with
our friend cassim and uh she said yes
and I just was like okay I'm doing it so
I got a
a plane we started we're like I landed
on a Thursday we recorded our first
episode the next day and when we started
this podcast and that was this is our
old podcast called pajama pants we like
I had never met Chasm so like we sat
down the three of us at a table we had
not discussed like what's this podcast
gonna be what's the vibe like we
literally just started talking the three
of us and we you know as podcasts do
like slowly found our groove and how
long did we do it for we did it for I
think like over two years and then uh
Tom Segura and Christina P were like hey
we love your pod we want you to do one
for us and I was like yeah let's [__]
dude I love I loved your mom's house and
actually the way that we met them was
because the people who produced pajama
pants our first podcast produced uh
tigerbelly which is Bobby Lee's pie yeah
so it was like a whole you know thing of
they got us in there and then we met
them and then they just uh yeah they
just liked our pot they just liked it
which was crazy I mean like we're like
Tom segur and Christina P like pajama
pants yeah yeah you know it's it's
they're they're they are who they are
and they're the best and then so I had
moved to Austin
and Tom and Christina live in Austin and
moved their ymh Studios to Austin as
well which then got robbed to move to
Austin oh so you moved you guys are all
in Austin yeah yeah do you I I was there
recently I don't love Austin but I
probably didn't see enough of it it's
just like the the downtown area near the
club just seemed kind of desolate at
night and it's a little it's still like
a little zombie-ish but maybe that's
just where I was that's just where you
were yeah I'm a guy where I'm like if
I'm not in New York everywhere is the
same you know what I mean like I'm like
so it's what's what's there for me right
now or this is like I love living in New
York but when I'm if when I was in Vegas
when I was in LA when I was in Austin
I'm like I could just make this work
like it's fine everywhere I'm just like
this isn't New York you know it's like
right New York the way that you can like
at any time walk out the door and get
whatever the [__] you need is that's how
I grew up so it's like not having that
is a very weird thing to me where like
it's like hey it's eight o'clock are you
sure you have everything you need
because yeah like I remember there was
one day in Austin where it was
I think it was 36 degrees and I was
walking around in a hoodie I went to
Whole Foods at 6 p.m and they were
closed what downtown Austin and I was
like what and there was a security guard
there he's like yeah we're closed man
he's like it's it's freezing out
it's [__] 6 p.m on a week we lost
power because it was
there was a free this last year because
the city just is not equipped for wow
when it gets that cold yeah and I'm in a
hoodie looking at Whole Foods that gets
an apocalypse and I'm like yo I'm like
you guys don't understand like what do
you mean but people don't have that
thing that people have in New York and
other cities where it's like oh if I
don't show up to work someone else is
going to take my [__] job right right
like they're just kind of like you know
yeah it'll uh we'll just close Whole
Foods today yeah but when that happens
don't you go like I [__] miss New
York like this this annoys me oh my God
so much yeah so much just like not being
like how is how are deli's not a thing
everywhere like how do you not have a
[__] Deli like what do you mean you
don't have a deal I just I don't
understand but I guess you know being
raised here it's just but then if they
do have a dally they're usually terrible
yeah yeah but at least I know I can get
like a drink like you know what I mean I
could get liquid to put in my body at 10
p.m we're like we're like you just go
around places where you're like unless
you go to drive to a gas station you're
just like you're [__] yeah and you
guys tape once a week yep yeah once a
week is that why did you move there just
specifically to tape and to be close to
the studio well she already had lived
there she moved there during covet so I
guess so her kids could go to school
again
yeah what's one of the reasons yeah we
were just uh we were ready to leave La
kind of needed a little bit Venture for
our family and wanted to try somewhere
new I didn't I know that I could never
get my husband to move to New York so it
was you know
he's right there I mean you know and we
have two little kids so
where we we live a little bit outside of
the City of Austin we live in like the
Hill Country and it's just you know it's
a simple life but I really love it
um it's still creative and cool and we
have a group of friends that actually
moved from La around the same time so we
kind of had a community there already
but you know Austin's a cool it's a cool
City it's a it's Lake life is fun I've
never knew what that was like you know
there's definitely a lot of things to
experience that I've never experienced
before as being somebody that grew up in
New York and it's close enough to New
York but now we visit a lot more than
when we lived in La yeah it's not and so
many people during the pandemic just
move because it was such a weird time
yeah like you were just kind of floating
in this weird thing like it's never
going to be normal again and once things
started to get normal again a lot of
people regretted their moves like a lot
of people yeah I think people were like
I'm gonna move to Florida or I'm gonna
move to Georgia and then they're like
what the [__] am I doing here but you're
happy you like it there are other people
though that like
moved out of New York during the
pandemic that never would have moved
that's true it never would have lived
and then they get out of New York and
they're like oh my God this is way
better like this rules I never would
have gotten space I never would have
been able to breathe air I never
especially people with kids yeah yeah oh
hell yeah yeah our kids are thriving
there they like it oh yeah we have two
little boys that are obsessed with
sports and Texas sports or our life yes
yeah how far from the border are you
guys
it's far far I'm terrible with Texas
geography uh like we're far far right
yeah you can't see it from my yeah
what's your biggest export tremendously
stupid question I've just been reading
about Texas in the situation they're
having oh okay
I feel like in Austin because because of
sports we travel with our sun to
different places within Texas and
whenever I leave Austin I'm like oh this
is Texas where we live is not Texas
right yeah does it say we're four hours
from the water on there okay yeah that's
that's a lot of walking
when you're in Texas that you really
don't know where you are like it's such
a massive State and I've kind of played
everywhere there and you have no idea
like am I right above Juarez am I close
to that you have no idea where you are
yeah yeah
I thought the first thing you were gonna
bring up to me was about how I was in
your book
oh you were in my book you remember that
yes when you came to the HBO taping yeah
yeah yeah this is how dumb I am
and I thought of that this morning but I
forgot that I'd put it in the book
because I like like you know how like
you don't watch yours I don't watch
myself and I will not reread it I read
it probably back in 20078 and I just
haven't looked I would love though like
walking down the street and seeing you
reading your own book yeah yeah you're
supposed to egotistic especially if I
got hit by a truck how great would that
be what was he doing not laughing
um yeah I introduced you you came to I
was taping down and dirty it was that
was that four episode thing I did for
HBO where I hosted and there's a lot of
great Comics came from that jeselnick
and Whitney oh yeah
he was great oh was that the episode how
many episodes yeah yeah so I did uh
jessal Nick Artie Lange and then I
forget who else was on but jessal Nick
took that I mean he just [__] killed
yeah he was great and we had we had like
a kind of like a headline act on each
one Artie was one of them uh bill was
one dice was one and Patrice I think was
the fourth
um and I introduced you because I was
like I want to introduce Robert but I
pronounced your name wrong instead of
idler I said Robert ilyer I was like oh
[__] which isn't bad but then they made
him come out and do it again do it
that's what was because nobody in the
audience knows nobody they don't know
that my name was wrong they don't know
anything but then like there was this
weird thing where it was like almost
like a fire drill where like he came out
and was like oh everyone if you could
please like yeah HBO wants me to redo
this thing and I don't know it's about
me like I'm like oh what what happened
like you know and then this is but this
is why I'm this is why my Showbiz
instincts are just non-existent and I'm
dumb I should have said there was a
technical issue and then redone it but I
didn't I could never like your honesty
is true you're an honest guy I know like
two like a fault I just came out
um
[Music]
that was kind of it yeah
I'm honest everywhere except
relationships
well we all can't we can't be perfect
yeah very cool about it though but
remember is that what I wrote In the
book you were great yeah well I just I
felt bad because I knew the feel like I
know how you were feeling and I'm like
oh my God this sucks and I was like I'm
so happy I'm not really famous and
important because you would have killed
yourself like because you felt so bad
and it was just me like I can't imagine
if it was like you know well I was happy
with I knew you were coming they told us
you were coming and I was like oh this
is [__] great and it was my idea
introduce you I'm like I wanna I wanna
did somebody like when you get backstage
did somebody go like what what did you
call I don't remember why I did it
because it's been a long time I don't
remember if somebody said the name to me
wrong I just I just don't remember if I
thought that or if somebody goes no his
name and then I just said it like that
or if I I probably just panicked in the
moment like a [__] blinking idiot
well it was the only place where
everyone actually knew my name you know
it was a [__] HBO filming so they're
like they're in the back like ah you
know we know he got his name wrong yeah
the gaffer screamed at me yes everybody
knew yeah that was taped in uh was it in
Edgewood uh New Jersey or something it
was or maybe I forget aware I don't
remember maybe it may be Edgewood yeah
and I don't get many celebrities at my
events so I was very happy you came very
very real very rarely does anybody show
up they say they're going to show up and
they never do no dude just don't like
[__] I remember like see because I I
don't think I had ever been to a comedy
club before going to that show I
remember seeing Jessica being like oh
because so like the only comedy I'd ever
you know besides like on [__] CDs
back then or whatever but like that I
was like holy [__] this guy just [__]
yeah lit this place up like and he was
he had that
Cadence of just like he was who he was
from the beginning of just not giving a
[__] yeah he's a murderer I mean he's
like you know set up and probably and
it's always brutal and it's always funny
and you don't see it coming he's great
luck is great and there's also no
flapping him right like even if somebody
goes like ooh it's like his face remains
exactly the same he's unfazed yeah it's
like you're the he almost has like this
weird thing like South Park just pulled
this off too well you're the idiot if
you get upset right yeah I mean like you
can get upset if you want but it's like
you know what he does and if that
bothers you well then don't come do you
guys go to Joe's club uh do you go to
the comedy Mothership uh no we've been
talking about it because I that's the
one thing I haven't done since moving to
Austin is get into the comedy scene
um but I really wanted where I mean
we're always trying to line it up
whenever Tom and Christina are
performing but I would like to go to the
Mothership it's always been like either
you can or I can or they can or so we're
gonna go see Christina on a third I
think she does every Thursday at the
mothership and we're gonna go see her
and then uh she thinks she's doing today
and we're here so yeah and she left town
and then uh yeah when we had Tom Tom was
on our show last week and he was like oh
you uh next door then we're like oh
we're going in yeah but it's cool when
Tom was on the show he's like I don't
know I might go in tonight like I was
like that's so dope like you could just
decide like yeah I'm gonna go I'm gonna
go perform tonight yeah show up yeah
they have a nice fight did uh there was
a podcast was it a Laura Compton's
podcast yeah it was great she's a great
host and they have like a complex they
have like a giant Warehouse filled with
uh a compound yeah it's [__] crazy
like you go there and you're like it's
really set up nice it's a good vibe when
you go in there yeah and Christina says
it's like the the house that farts built
you know she's like it's just crazy that
you come in here and you see this place
and you're like oh there's something
like it's like when we filmed Sopranos
at Silver Cup like you're like this is a
[__] legit Studio there's people
moving [__] in and out changing sets
this and you're like wow this is yeah
they sent us like a call sheet yeah when
we record and they're like crew set up
the you know Jamie and Rob arrive this
time it's so official I love it and then
we get there and we're talking about
diarrhea yeah who had diarrhea by the
way you didn't specify no well I think I
think people we've had a poop but we
talk about poop we talk and then your
UTI was a big uh so so this is a thing
it's like Rob just like
doesn't let me get like away with
anything where I was like I'm sorry I
gotta go pee again and he was like and
so when I sat down he's like okay why
are you having to keep going to pee I'm
like 30 minutes
well let me get away with it so I
did in my head I can't believe this is
going to continue so I had mentioned
that I was like suffering at the moment
from UTI and then I showed up the next
week and Rob had all of his celebrity
friends create uh like a in memoriam
type video for me a sympathy video let's
try some beautiful music
um yeah it was it was epic were you like
uh a big comedy podcast fans that got it
into your head that we should just do
this yeah I mean I I loved Stern back in
the day like the already years I [__]
love yeah uh and then I got really into
uh your mom's house and tigerbelly yeah
I just like the big the beginning of
tigerbelly when Bobby Lee just like
didn't understand fully that this was
going out to the world the [__] that I
mean on on the when he used to come into
it was this when he used to come in and
tell his stories
holy [__] man he is just a [__]
National Treasure yeah he to me there's
nobody more entertaining he's hilarious
and he's so one of my you know Sopranos
isn't like an anime so he's never seen
it you know he has no clue who I am so
he uh we we went to film the um your
mom's house says live shows sometimes so
he goes um and I had just gotten hired
by them and he they're filming stuff
like in in the pre-show or whatever and
he and he has no idea who I am he looks
at me and he goes I want to get I want
to get naked and walk by and I go oh I
go okay go ahead and he goes well no I
want to make sure it's okay with Tom and
Christine I go I work here it's fine
like
I've never heard so fast a belt buckle
hit a floor he didn't
hands he just wiggled and his [__]
pants Hit the Floor he put his hand over
his [__] and he walked to where they
were filming and just destroyed the
entire [__] thing that they were
doing that they had planned for like
months you know what I mean and he's
just walking around like he doesn't know
where he is butt naked and I'm like this
guy is so [__] hot and funny yeah
he's just so good and you guys did this
his show no no never but he uh he's the
same producers as him yeah he just he he
thought that I was a guy who just like
you know it was like a you know set
building sets at ymh but then all you
had to say was I work here
okay yeah well I was like what else
would I be doing there you know there's
only like 10 people there he's like well
how else would I get in the door you
know they have like you know [__]
you're not just walking in the door so
he's like I'm like yeah I work here he's
like okay bang she's the same producers
he's in he's in LA right yeah he's in LA
and we were doing uh so the reason we
stopped doing our podcast was because uh
when she moved to Austin we started over
zoom and zoom is death yeah it's hard
yeah Zoom is just [__] terrible well
I mean at first it started in covet
obviously right right right yeah yeah
many episodes
um and then it just continued and yeah I
mean it was just it was just hard to
keep the Rhythm and we did we did our
best and we had we had such a loyal
group of listeners to pajama pants they
were small and mighty and like any time
I would meet somebody that listened I
was like oh you get me like you know me
you know what I mean that just felt like
I felt like such a kinship with them
Jamie ordered chairs One Time online and
they didn't show up on time and people
were ready to like go to London
yeah I thought I had like my identity
stolen and people were like yeah people
were ready to go to bat for me yeah well
that's yeah I mean podcasts are like so
intimate that now people feel like they
know you yeah like the fact that people
would come up to you with soprano stuff
that you're like I really have no idea
what you're talking about because I
don't watch a show like have you gotten
to the point yet where people are coming
up to you talking about your real life
and you're like I forgot that we talked
about this I don't know what you're
saying yes yeah it's weird right yes I
know people know like what I they're
like oh did you eat chicken again today
you know because they're just like I'm
like I just eat chicken every I eat once
a day and I just eat chicken every day
and people are like oh did you eat yeah
yeah and like have you know it's weird
yes it is a weird thing because you're
like yeah but I don't know you to have
this conversation right because when
people used to say [__] it was like you
know something about Tony this and I'm
like I don't know where now it's like oh
yeah no I haven't eaten yet I'm actually
kind of hungry you know it's weird and
when you're sitting across from somebody
that you are very close with and have
like a genuine relationship with and so
when him and I talk even though we're
like I'm aware that we're on a set and
there's cameras and we have our booth
boys and you know we're talking like I'm
still talking to Rob so it can't help
but get personal yeah right yeah you're
so comfortable yeah if you were on like
a press tour or something or doing
interviews on a show or you were on this
show and we were like tell us about your
UTI you'd be like the [__] are you what
is this show I've been broken down so
hard at this point though
yeah whatever they're such a great and
that's what's so great about like like
you know because they do Dr Drew's show
and other people were like they face the
cameras and they face the booth boys so
it's like very you're reminded it's like
being a news anchor you're reminded that
there's a production where I asked them
I was like can we Face each other yeah
so that you can completely forget and
the safety of knowing hey this doesn't
come out for a few days so if you decide
a day or two later that you want to edit
it we don't have to have that angst of
like should I say this should I not it's
like say whatever the [__] you want
right and then if tomorrow you want that
out it's no problem like it's so much
better to be comfortable we could not
have done this podcast though when I was
in my 20s and early 30s where like I
cared more do you know what I mean I
feel like you're catching me right now
at a time where my kids I finally got to
this stage of like Parenthood where I'm
like can breathe a little bit I'm like a
little exhausted a little relieved and
just care a whole lot less yeah and it's
probably like that's when like you're
gonna do your best stuff and you're
gonna be happiest and you're gonna be
like I really should to stop carrying a
long time ago yes yes yeah and I also
just I always knew like I'm not an actor
you know what I mean like I knew it
wasn't fit like when I did Sopranos I
was like I love this and so I thought I
loved acting and then when I tried to do
acting after it I was like oh this isn't
that like this and that's what everybody
on soprano said like they had been
acting for 10 20 30 years so they were
like you don't know how lucky you are
and I was 12 I was like oh everyone
doesn't get on a hit show like yeah you
know so I I really didn't know and then
afterwards you go and you do stuff and
like people stay in their campers and
they show up and they do their lines and
they go back and that's where we were
like we were waiting for them to yell
cut so we could like all sit at the bar
together and talk and laugh and do
stupid [__] and it was just you know we
couldn't wait like nobody wanted to go
to the Emmys but everybody wanted to
hang out and and you know it was like oh
who's on my flight and you'd get so
excited by like who's on my flight
because I don't get to do scenes with
this person but now we're going to be on
the same flight for six hours right